there's an attack coming I need four
years stop right there
I'm in you are yeah I need friends on my
knee let's do it
blacks are
dressed like a bat you really are out of
your mind I'm not the one who brought a
pitchfork
Justice League
I'm building an alliance there are
enemies coming
I need warriors I just push some people
run away
let's go
[Music]
it might not assault back through
Justice League experience in IMAX
[Music]
I'm putting together to you
people with special abilities
[Music]
stop right there I'm in you are just
like that yeah I need friends the flash
joins forces with Batman Wonder Woman
Aquaman and Cyborg and in doing so we
become the greatest superhero team ever
Oh awesome
let's talk about the dynamic Bruce is
actively trying to find these
superhumans that he believes are out
there this is the first time after many
years that she starts working in a team
again to make the world a better place
there's a very interesting team dynamic
half-man half-machine cyborg is the
perfect combination of Technology and
the human heart Aquaman
he kills from two different worlds he's
human a nice Atlanta
flash has the ability to experience time
more slowly honestly I'm having too much
fun
[Music]
don't engage alone we do this together
let's do it
Oh
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
[Music]
good morning after the death of Superman
violence acts of war and terrorism are
all on the rise I had a dream it was the
end of the world
I think it's something more something
darker
we're asking people we done know to risk
their lives strong man and strong is
alone never heard that it's not a saying
that's the opposite of what the saying
is
divided we are not enough
[Music]
worldly super
[Music]
promise
why I brought you together
ride ain't over yet man
[Music]
[Music]
Oh awesome as a bad signal that's your
oh sorry
it's your signal that means we have to
go now yeah I sort of mean it's so cool
you